um funny right yeah it was a good video
Our Generation man you know our humor is
different yeah yeah wait what do you
mean our comedies light years ahead
we're a generation raised on the
internet our humor is both based in
logic and
not logic yeah it does seem like there's
a lot more absurdism now you know lots
of non-sequiturs our comedy isn't even
funny or anti-fung it is post-post
modern a post-ironic pseudo-halarious
decentralized market of references in
jokes and meta-ironic memes it's like if
Cars 2 met Shrek and had a baby that
doesn't sound very weird actually I mean
think about comedy of the past you know
old guys with long white beards walking
sticks feeding pigeons on a park bench
what now man with transcended post-post
ironic funny modern Pastiche past
meta-ironic posts to the realm of
pure calm a video is called Plankton
farts and dies astrophy